time for pft on yahoo sports peter king
mike floyer some of the big story lines
in the national football league plenty
of story lines coming out of week one
peter let's begin in the nfc north where
the green bay packers went to an empty
u.s bank stadium and took down the
minnesota vikings dismantled them the
most points the vikings have ever given
up in a season opening game in their
60-year history so are the packers still
the nfc north favorites after what we
saw out of them week one
you know i think what was really
interesting what i noticed i watched a
lot of this game as i'm sure you did too
mike what was really interesting about
this game to me
is that the minnesota vikings both in
the front end and the back end
could not stop the green bay passing
game
and what i what i mean by that is that
the vikings in the last five or six
years have used so much draft capital on
that back end you know and and
and obviously now they have torn that up
and are starting to rebuild it so that
really was one part of it but the other
part of it was
you know without danielle hunter i think
everybody thought that hey
you know they're going to be okay they
got in gawkway they can scotch tape it
together
uh
you know
until denial hunter gets back after
probably three weeks but no
there was no way and
the other thing i thought of mike is
you know aaron rodgers walking into the
locker room after the game just saying
okay you want to replace me
i'll show you how you replace me
and and and just really thinking to
himself
you know i i i'm still
the best on a given sunday in the nfl
and to me
mike i honestly think i and i and i
thought this on the night of the draft
that there is
a decent chance that jordan ends up as
green based jimmy garoppolo
you know because you tell me right now
how much of a chance in the next two and
a half three years
is aaron rodgers going to plum it off a
cliff
i i i don't i don't see it and that's
why to me uh man i understand why you
want to protect yourself at quarterback
but
that was just vintage aaron rodgers on
sunday
i think at a certain level packers ceo
mark murphy likes the fact that aaron
rodgers finds motivation in these
potential
areas of dysfunction and motivation
abounds and here's what astounded me
from that game two things first of all
we really saw what it means
to have a loud crowd at home
on third down or not to have a loud
crowd at home on third down when you
have an opportunity to rattle green bay
you don't get that edge you don't get
that advantage with your pass rushers
jumping the snap because
they see it when the packers offensive
line sees it if you're going on a silent
account but the other thing is this
peter
the vikings have dom capers on the staff
now if there's any coach in the nfl that
is going to help other than mike
mccarthy if there's any coach that's
going to help figure out how to stop
aaron rodgers it's a guy who had
multiple years at practice with him and
in games with him and would you would
have something that could slow this guy
down capers had nothing
yeah not only did he have nothing mike
but i
i think this is one of those cases you
know
where you think of players make plays
and at some point a coach can do
whatever he wants but i don't care how
much knowledge you have about aaron
rodgers you tell me how you're going to
stop
that toe tap touchdown pass to devonta
adams you know with one blade of grass
before the side of the end zone the huge
white stripe you know and to me that's
what i think when i think of aaron
rodgers you can have all the schemes you
want against him when he's playing like
that or playing like the jared cook pass
against the dallas cowboys a few years
ago you're not stopping them you're just
not
they got the lions at the saints and the
falcons before an early bye after that a
trip to tampa bay for aaron rodgers
versus tom brady so the packers in a
position to get off to a great start
pick up where they left off last year
and right now i'll say it they are the
favorites in the nfc north for more pft
on yahoo check us out all season long
have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports